plan the most interesting idea that I
had today was from Chris Hayes who is
very interesting chat and he has this
whole theory of fractal inequality in
the world and in countries and even in
Davos and in fact over reuters.com the
fabulous onion Shiffrin was a blog entry
jealous jealous Davos mistresses but
never mind the jail staff post
mistresses what she broke if the genius
of the World Economic Forum is that it
quote is that couch workers could have
been able to persuade hundreds of
accomplished businessmen to pay
thousands of dollars to an attends an
event which is largely based on mass
humiliation and paranoia basically
everyone thinks that the most
interesting parties are somewhere else
everyone wants the next level up of
badge color you know it's different
color badges and everyone is full of
trying to work and who they're more
important than who's more important than
them and is very very afraid that you
know there's some great party going on
something I wish they don't know about
but this is a microcosm of the world
right so if you look at the world as a
whole then 80% of the world's population
lives in a way that we would probably
consider and could be unlivable and more
- did you the well you know we don't
consider ourselves particular lucky in
relation to them because we're just
looking up at the 20% above us and
saying who we want to be even more every
and every point that would you zoom into
the distribution right I mean as you
know this exponential increase like but
it's certainly true the u.s. context in
which you
into the top 20% the politics of class
resentment new eyes are actually
structured around this movement to a
larger is because much of the politics
that we've seen Phillip on both sides of
the political spectrum left Emma right
Tea Party and move on for instance are
really upper middle class revolts there
are no platform holes that are
channeling class resentment or detaching
itself from the rest of that top 20% and
then you zoom in again a divorce you
know you zoom into that tumbler that
have 1% and you see the same sort of
distribution it sort of reading scribed
as and even within the top 0.1% they
still feel this way they never become
secure in there they always you know now
one of my sort of big picture views of
the world has always been that well what
we're seeing is increasing inequality
within countries especially if you look
at the number of billionaires who are
being created like Mexico China India
increasing anybody really has you put
decreasing and quality between country
yeah so the difference between the US
and China has never been smaller that's
why I mean on since about
so so is there somewhere in this
exponential graph is is the fact that
the countries of the world are coming
together maybe the sort of silver lining
of this and even though we're seeing
this global international
photographically it's somehow because
rural countries like that and they're
all in the same boat that somehow that's
going to help improve muscle disease
international so they're ready of the
working man I have no that would be
great but I mean I think from my
perspective sustainable just and so and
so the question is whether that is I
think distinct from the question of what
kind of social welfare state and they
make noises about increasing land
there's small things but I really want
to hope that the increased prosperity
that we see poverty as it has continued
to do but that's combined with some real
kind of
robust improvements so there yeah but
and and thank you for your question
Brian and I hope we've ugly failed my
office Cheers